es war höchste Zeit und man kann
eigentlich den Bayern nur dankbar sein
dass sie die ersten sind die hier
tatsächlich das Thema mal wieder gerade
rücken und nicht mehr mit zweierlei Maß
messen dieser Razzia heute die sich eben
die ganz klar eben auch juristisch
betrachtet und sagt hier ist eine
Organisationsstruktur wo Verbrechen
sozusagen Straftaten geplant werden wo
Gelder gesammelt werden und dass man
eben auch nicht nur einfach nur auf die
Leute schaut sondern auch sagt wir
frieren jetzt endlich mal die konnten
ein und schauen uns die Geldgeber an
denn was der das gerne vernachlässigt
wird und was auch im politischen Raum
nicht so gerne diskutiert wird ist die
Frage wer finanziert eigentlich das
ganze wer hat eigentlich ein Interesse
daran dass in Deutschland klimakinder
auf der Straße kleben und warum zahlen
eigentlich global agierende Investoren
und irgendwelche Fonds aus Amerika
deutsche klimaaktivisten um die Politik
zu unterstützen die in Deutschland dazu
führt dass Deutschland die
industrialisiert wird dass Deutschlands
Energieversorgung den Bach hinunter geht
insofern würde ich sagen follow the
money und lasst uns endlich einmal
anschauen wer eigentlich diejenigen
hinter den nützlichen Idioten sind die
gerade als sogenannte letzte Generation
auf der Straße kleben lassen sie uns da
mal ganz konkret wenn sie haben sich das
nämlich genauer angeschaut wer sitzt
dahinter jetzt sind gerade alle Konten
eingefrorene und auch die Behörden
werfen darauf jetzt mal ja wir sagen die
die Untersuchung dazu ist ja nicht so
dass wir gar kein Wissen hätten sondern
es gibt es gibt verschiedene
internationale Fonds und
erstaunlicherweise sind das eigentlich
Großinvestoren auch die die hier
offensichtlich eine Politik unterstützen
in Europa also auch nicht nur jetzt
irgendwie die hier die letzte Generation
sondern auch Fridays for future auch
Exchange Extension Rebellion das heißt
die gesamte Klima Bewegung in Europa ist
finanziert durch Millionenbeträge zum
Beispiel von diesem kleinen
aber auch andere sozusagen auch reiche
Einzelpersonen die das Ganze
finanzieren und da muss man einfach mal
schauen wer profitiert eigentlich am
Schluss und wir sehen ja jetzt auch in
der Verflechtung zum Beispiel mit mit
der Energiepolitik dass wir hier ja
genauso sehen es profitieren auch große
Investoren aus dem Ausland wenn in
Deutschland
wir nicht einmal unsere Wärmepumpen mehr
selber produzieren können sondern wenn
wir jetzt quasi darauf angewiesen sind
sie aus dem Ausland zu kaufen dass das
Ausland ein Interesse daran hat dass in
Deutschland die Energieversorgung nicht
mehr autark ist dass eben im Ausland man
Geschäfte damit machen kann wenn die
Deutschen ihre Autoindustrie verlieren
und wenn
Schlüsselindustrien wie Stahl oder auch
Chemie plötzlich abwandern das heißt das
was im Moment vordergründig passiert
dass da irgendwelche Kinder auf der
Straße kleben wird finanziert von großen
von global agierenden Investoren die auf
der auf dem anlang waren wie man so
schön sagt anschließend davon
profitieren dass Deutschland
wirtschaftlich geschwächt ist und man
muss natürlich auch die Frage aufmachen
wieso spielt eigentlich unsere Regierung
hier mit inwiefern sind hier eigentlich
auch die ganzen deutschen Institute also
sozusagen die Clan ich will dich sagen
Kleinkriminalität aber wir haben ja
klaren Strukturen bis in die Regierung
hinein ja dass wir Institute wie agora
haben die Umwelthilfe was weiß ich wir
wissen noch nicht einmal wer welche
Institute alle sich eigentlich
gegenseitig Gutachten schreiben um eine
eine Politik zurechtfertigen wo wir
sagen also auch die Verwicklungen
untereinander auch da sind ja auch
verwackelt fast schon in ihrem Thema
drin lassen Sie uns einmal auch noch bei
der Razzia bleiben welche Erkenntnisse
erhoffen sie sich durch diese Razzia ja
ich finde tatsächlich dass wir jetzt
über diese Frage überhaupt diskutieren
wer finanziert das wer hat eine
Interesse daran weil das wird immer so
getan ja das sind eben Jugendliche die
machen sich Sorgen um die Zukunft und
wir haben vielleicht etwas kreativer Art
die auszudrücken diese Sorgen und auf
der anderen Seite natürlich bei den
Menschen wächst die blanke Wut weil
ständig also wenn man das ist ja
wirklich eine so eklatante Störung der
öffentlichen Ordnung die Leute können
nicht mehr zur Arbeit fahren die können
ihre Kinder nicht abholen wenn einer
eilig ins Krankenhaus muss dann hängt er
in seinem Auto und kommt nicht weiter
also es ist ja jetzt keine Kleinigkeit
und ich meine ich bin wirklich jemand
der sich immer dagegen wehren würde
zivilen Ungehorsam zu kriminalisieren
also wenn Menschen echte eigene
Interessen haben und sich wehren wenn
Landwirte nach Berlin kommen mit ihren
Traktoren und den verkehren lahmlegen
dass das muss also ich will nie in einer
Gesellschaft leben wo sowas dann
kriminalisiert und drakonisch bestraft
wird aber den Klima Klebern das ist
offensichtlich ja eine wirklich
ausgefeilte Organisation und es ist eine
mit hohen finanzbeträgen ausgestattete
Organisation ich meine auch der
klimafolsentscheid hier in Berlin habe
ich gelesen hat ja auch sehr sehr gerne
sehr viel Geld bekommen und es sind
überwiegend amerikanische Geldgeber und
ich frag mich wieso findet das
eigentlich nicht in den USA statt
normalerweise
wieder auf der Straße kleben sind ja
diejenigen die sagen sie wollen den
Systemwechsel sie wollen gegen
Kapitalismus kämpfen und in Wahrheit von
einem Turbokapitalismus finanzieren und
das interessante eben der Unterschied ja
auch zu sagen wir mal zu irgendwelchen
Landwirten die jetzt sagen wir wir
wollen wir wir legen mal kurz den
Verkehr lahm ist ja dass wir hier eben
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
hier von organisierter Kriminalität
sprechen oder von einer
Organisationsstruktur weil hier werden
ja Aktivisten gezielt bezahlt das heißt
das sind ja nicht irgendwie eben das
sind ja nicht naive Kinder ja vielleicht
sind Sie vielleicht zumindest Akteur
vielleicht wissen nicht was sie tun
teilweise sondern sie finden das toll
aber es wird ja eben auch bezahlt also
das ist eine ganz neue Qualität also als
ich in dem Alter war irgendwie musste
man noch mit Strafen rechnen irgendwie
und mit Anzeigen und heute ist die
Politik duldet das nicht nicht nur
sondern sie geht sogar darauf ein also
das ein Verkehrsminister Wissen anstatt
irgendwie den Verfassungsschutz
anzurufen die Leute zum Gespräch bittet
obwohl sie mit Erpressung und mit
Nötigung irgendwie Millionen von Bürgern
in eine Sippenhaft mit hineinnehmen das
geht eigentlich nicht normalerweise
sagen wir dass wir dass wir auf solche
mit solchen Leuten die die Demokratie
und auch die normalen demokratischen
Prozesse ja nicht anerkennen ja die
jetzt bürgergeräte gründen wollen das
ist verfassungsfeindlich war eigentlich
müsste man auch der Verfassungsschutz
müsste endlich aktiv werden und
stattdessen lädt man Sie ein zum
Gespräch ganz ganz wichtig
wir schauen einmal gemeinsam rein und
heute gab es auch eine Pressekonferenz
der letzten Generation und darüber würde
ich auch gleich in dieser Runde gerne
sprechen
wir glauben an den Rechtsstaat wir
appellieren jeden Tag an ihn wir haben
keine Angst vor einem Prozess wir haben
Angst vor der Zerstörung unseres
Rechtsstaates durch die Folgen der
Klimakrise
Staatsanwälte aus ganz Deutschland haben
bereits klar gemacht dass sie den
Vorwurf einer kriminellenvereinigung für
komplett absurd halten aber was sind das
für Untersuchungen bei denen schon durch
Sperrung unserer Webseite und unserer
Konten so tief in unsere Organisation
eingegriffen wird und dadurch unser
legitimer Protest behindert wird das
also die Pressekonferenz heute Email von
Wahlen die sich dort geäußert hatte
Fragen von Journalisten waren auf dieser
Pressekonferenz nicht zugelassen Alter
wollen wir über dieses Thema habe ich
gerade gesagt diskutieren halten Sie
diese Razzia für überzogen das ginge
Argument ist jetzt sie wieder Ungehorsam
das hat auch Frau Wagenknecht gerade
angeführt muss sein und das eben
zugunsten für den Kampf für das Klima
also ich glaube grundsätzlich selbst
wenn es da auch wirklich viele
Aktivisten gibt die legitime Ziele
verfolgen die wirklich daran glauben
dass man irgendwas tun muss und
natürlich das Klima zu retten und so
weiter glaube ich dass man diese Energie
viel eher positiv nutzen sollte und ich
glaube nicht dass man auf diese Art und
Weise irgendwas wirklich positives
bewirkt denn man bringt ja eigentlich
die Menschen die man ja erreichen will
gegen sich auf und auf diese Art und
Weise wird sich doch gar nichts
verändern die sollten doch eigentlich
eher versuchen uns mit einzuspannen über
die Dinge die wir vielleicht aus ihrer
Sicht nicht Bescheid wissen und darüber
aufklären aber es passiert ja gar nicht
sich einfach da auf dem Boden fest zu
kleben mit irgendeinem Kleber der weiß
ich nicht woher gestellt wird und bin
mir auch nicht so sicher ob der so
klimafreundlich ist ja ähm sich da
sozusagen den Verkehr lahm zu legen wo
die Leute dann auch noch ihre Abgase in
die Luft rein blasen was ist das Auto
laufen lassen eineinhalb Stunden das
sorgt nur für Frust und was diese Razzia
und so weiter und diese rechtlichen
Sachen angeht da muss man sich das dann
genau von den Experten anschauen lassen
ich bin kein
Rechtsanwalt aber ich glaube der
Rechtsstaat in Deutschland ist stark
genug um sich der Sache zu widmen
diese Form des Protest zumindest nicht
für zielführend Frau Rossbach ist es
trotzdem eine Form des Protestes ähm ja
der die Demokratie so etwas muss die
Demokratie eben einfach aushalten
ganz eindeutig das ist für mich auch ein
dunkelrotes Tuch da werden Grenzen
überschritten ich finde es sehr sehr gut
was jetzt passiert ist dass das man
wirklich so aufs Tableau kommt bevor du
musst dich ja wehrhaft zeigen du kannst
ja nicht ständig von morgens abends auf
der Nase rumtanzen lassen das spaltet
die Gesellschaft ist es giftig wie man
richtig wo morgens abends drüber auf es
bringt nichts ist der Sache nicht
förderlich und alles immer unter dem
Deckmäntelchen ist guten ja so öffnet
die TV-Studios die bekommen hier
wärmster gesehen die Sitze nicht nur
Pressekonferenzen wer von uns wer von
uns bürgerlich ja die sich ich engagiere
mich auch mein Leben lang ehrenamtlich
ich versuche wirklich was zu machen ja
und und sie sitzt mir da in ewig lange
Nacht Sitzungen ja und was man nicht
alles tut und Menschen zu erreichen ja
jeder der politisch und Partei
Strukturen ja sich irgendjemand
ausgetobt hat weiß was das heißt und das
nicht alles von alles von heute auf
morgen geht und alles mit radikalen
Umbruch und ich lasse es nicht mehr zu
das ist immer so die Generation ist die
jungen Leute ich bin nämlich auch eine
Vertreterin der sogenannten jungen
Generation die sagten die haben auch
ganz andere Sorgen das macht nur Ärger
der spaltet ich halte es für für
hochgradig Problem dadurch dass wir da
auch jetzt erstmal auf die Idee kommen
zu gucken überhaupt mal Razzien
durchzuführen und mal richtig darauf in
die Bresche rein zu gehen ich würde mir
das überhaupt nicht mehr gefallen lassen
leben sie trotzdem nach ja noch eins
anfangen weil eben es sind ja viele die
jetzt sagen ja das sei überzogen und das
sei übertrieben was jetzt passiert und
dass die dass sich die Staatsgewalt
jetzt hier überzieht ich würde jedem
einfach nur einladen in das
Gedankenexperiment wenn wir hier nicht
über die letzte Generation sprechen
würden die für das Klima auf der Straße
klebt sondern wenn das Reichsbürger
werden die jetzt seit Monaten was über
alles machen würden dann wäre breite
Einigkeit in der Politik in den Medien
und überall dass man die schon längst
hätte verhaften müssen und so weiter das
heißt das was jetzt passiert und das mag
jetzt manche erschüttern weil sie immer
mitsamt Handschuhen angefasst worden
sind aber das was jetzt passiert ist
einfach dass der nur dass der
Rechtsstaat einfach alle gleich
behandelt und zwar eben die diese Leute
jetzt auch endlich so behandelt wie sie
eigentlich die ganze Zeit schon
behandelt hätten werden müssen wie jede
andere politische Gruppierung auch dass
gesagt wenn hier ein Anfangsverdacht ist
dass das kriminelle Tätigkeiten sind und
das hier Strukturen geschaffen werden
irgendwie um Menschen eine zur
Straftaten direkt sogar anzustacheln
dann muss der Rechtsstaat der sich nicht
lächerlich machen will muss er sogar
agieren um einfach alle Bürger gleich zu
behandeln und als letztes Beispiel
während der corona-pandemie ich fand es
wirklich erschütternd da sind Menschen
auf die Straße gegangen von Rentner bis
zu Familien um für ihre Bürgerrechte zu
demonstrieren und daran zu erinnern dass
ja im Grundgesetz steht dass sie diese
Rechte haben die würden mit
Wasserwerfern von der Straße gedrängt
und jetzt regen sich hier welche auf
weil sie eine Hausdurchsuchung hatten da
kann ich nur sagen heul leiser
aber es war wirklich auch in ihrer
Partei Lorenz gestern
Untersuchung als überzogen er sagt die
letzte Generation auf friedlichen
zivilen Ungehorsam um eben auf die
Klimakatastrophe aufmerksam zu machen ja
ich halte das für völlig daneben also
ich bin in keiner Weise irgendwie der
Meinung dass das ein legitimer Protest
ist und ehrlich gesagt es ist ja auch
wirklich in einer Weise organisiert das
ist keine Interessenpolitik das sind
nicht verzweifelte Leute die auf die
Straße gehen weil sie ständig überrollt
werden von der Politik weil ihre Stimme
nicht gehört wird sondern das ist
offensichtlich etwas was ganz klar
finanziert organisiert wird da stehen
Interessen dahinter ich finde es ganz
wichtig dass wir jetzt mal über solche
Interessen reden das sind nämlich
Wirtschaftsinteressen wir dürfen auch
nicht mal so blauäugig sein also es wird
jetzt immer so alles moralisiert die
ganze Welt ist moralisch wir sind
moralisch wir sind die guten nein wir
leben in einer Gesellschaft wo es
knallharte wirtschaftliche Interessen
gibt und auch Konkurrenz und
beispielsweise gibt es natürlich
wirtschaftliche Konkurrenz zwischen
Unternehmen den USA oder ein anderer
Ländern und deutschen Unternehmen und es
gibt auch Interessen daran Deutschland
ich meine das wurde immer kritisiert hat
noch wahrscheinlich nicht mehr lange
aber eine starke Exportwirtschaft ist
ein Land das in bestimmten Bereichen
auch sehr sehr gut positioniert ward war
und natürlich gibt's Interesse daran das
kaputt zu machen und das ist aber das
ist dieses Interesse gibt ist ja durch
aus nachvollziehbar und was für mich
nicht nachvollziehbar ist dass wir eine
Bundesregierung haben die das irgendwie
mitmacht und bei der man das Gefühl hat
ist sie eigentlich noch die legitim
interessenvertreterin oder die willige
Interessen Vertreterin der Menschen die
hier leben